this is just amazing
what this young player devin booker a
two-time all-star
has done in close-out games in big games
against lebron and the lakers at staples
in game six
and again tonight with his 34
in game four against the denver night
sons are going to the conference finals
[Applause]
[Music]
and a performance for the ages from
chris paul
but everybody got a hand on this one
crowder tonight 10 rebounds
and nine points and paul had seven
assists with his
37 booker had 34 and 11
rebounds and was so steady every inch of
the way
and now the suns will sit
and wait and rest for who's to come out
of the jazz
clippers series and that has a long way
to go still
you talking about the potential match of
phoenix and and the clippers
you've got the claw and pg
michael malone used a lot of respect yep
new orleans
as an assistant coach under monty
williams
a lot of history there as well torrey
craig who used to play
for denver was part of the last two
playoff runs
has been one of the wonderful players
off the bench providing depth
coach and player
it's great to see sportsmanship after
the game look at this
a lot of love here between monty
williams and cp3
chris paul a lot of history paul was
talking about
the attention to detail that every
scouting report
every game plan has
but tonight this was a game
people remember for a long time
chris paul there are a lot of suns fans
here by the way folks there
are a ton of phoenix suns
they travel well they do crazy what
about that chris what do you think of
all those fans up there man that's sick
that's sick we ran out for warm-ups it
felt like a home game yeah
i ain't been on a team like this to
travel like this that's crazy
we're going to pass the baton over to
chris haynes but from reggie and i we
want to congratulate you you gave us
a thrill tonight in every every
performance chris
haynes take it away chris you got this
team
to the western conference finals how
difficult was it to get this game
when that team's identity suddenly
changed once the joker went out
man god is good tell you man it's a
tough team over there
we're joking without them they will
coach they play hard they compete
and we knew once joker went out that was
just going to open the door for a lot of
other guys so
we just tried to stay the course over
these last couple of games
offensively you took it up to another
notch and particularly
with that mid-range game how important
is the mid-range game still in the game
that's important to me
you know some years ago uh when i played
with the clippers the whole league went
to this drop defense
you know what a man and i was like
that's what y'all gonna give up i'm
gonna try to perfect it
you know but it's not about that i i i'm
so grateful to my family my team
a couple years ago it was writing me off
you can't do this and this ain't about
me it's about us
show you what you can do when you come
together as a team we got a great team
over there
and it's a lot a lot of fun to be a part
of it you're going on weight the winner
between the clippers
and the jazz but in the meantime cp
what are the expectations of this team
what is the ceiling of this team this
season we're just gonna keep playing
hard
you know you never know what the future
holds we're gonna keep playing hard
now we're gonna get some rest it's a
much needed rest but uh
it's special man and these fans we thank
y'all so much man seriously got my moms
and pops here my older brother
it's all love all good appreciate you
chris
thank you dog sons fans and these
nuggets fans that have remained here
wonderful scene paul
[Music]
[Applause]
and what has he done he has changed
what people perceive the phoenix suns to
be
a perennial loser now they're in the
conference
finals